sono entrato la prima cosa che ho visto
è e sasha se ti metti un sacchetto in
testa di c bomber e ha tenuto la pistola
e basta no no no no non sto scappando
con la nave quelle paziente no ragazzi
di santa l'obiettivo sasha è quello di
depredare i tesori sulle isole capito e
se incontriamo altre navi buttarli giù
il problema di questo gioco che per fare
tutto questo deve avere una nave e la
nave chi ce l'ha da troglodita li
madonna torna indietro pietro signori e
signore ardua e sasha 26 30 mag a non
suonare pietro per l'amor di dio tu dove
sul suo nome
porca vacca qua guarda premi f4f toni f
e quando arriva la nave il tassista non
spara prima che sono per dire a
cannonate ok ok pietro non si fare la
stessa cosa non suonare grassi non vedo
nessuna barca quella davanti la stiamo
per approcciare te lo dico io fino a di
ok occhio raga ma occhio raga
ma sei scema pietro ma non dobbiamo in
tornare allo sbaraglio ma sei idiota
pietro come faccio a spararle sbagliato
sono salito sono salito sono salito che
ha sparato
ora fatto un tesoro in questa battaglia
poi grandissimo l'hack è male io non
sono qui stavano procedere laga dove
dovete attaccare la nave sta affondando
mi aggrappo bosco era non mi pesa di più
mi hanno visto draga allora ma chi è il
problema
passiamo di fianco gli spara null di
vincoli donna guarda ma sei un deficit
che problemi hai man ma dopo queste sono
morto comuni di deficienti lega dei
deficienti
allora la situazione della nave datemi
una giornata un atelier nacini stiamo
affrontando ma se messi di merda
un'altra nave sta formando affondata e
fondata da sciami di quadri sono ancora
in giro anna spingi ok ma perché i
lavori sono state le donne
vorrei che siamo maschilisti sì ma
dobbiamo andare esattamente dove sono
morti quell'isola lì a sinistra c'è
ancora gente sull'isola ragazza vi
spariamo
c'è anche un agente sull'isola visto un
tizio a no uno scheletro sono due schede
e allora ragazzi io sulla loro nave ho
dovuto prenderlo ho preso un tesoro ma
poi l'ho buttato giusto perché ok a
genova c'è un tizio giudizio certi
giochi celtici del tesoro sta scappando
uccido sasha sceglie lo sappiamo lo
sparatore sparato zio
ok lo ammazzo la mazzola mazzo
tranquillo e ucciso ucciso preso tesoro
preso dove di questo questo è il bottino
ok è raro prenderlo siamo stati molto
bravi
oggi non gira ma sai che lascia tutti
sti episodi non abbiamo mai fatto quello
che abbiamo appena detto una donna s'è
informato e ho una forza nelle brava
faccio palestra
ok quando prendi i soldi dove li
portiamo vai sotto coperte di nascondi e
così mentre dietro pilota con la
tempesta se tu guardi che c'è questa
roba
ti riprendi la il bicchiere che
permetterà ad essa lo prendi e vai a
vedere levi bel po bevi un bel po ok
interviene groggy crocker e filler e
vile beni stabili che continua avere ma
che offre come la piazza ora salito
pensa lì sopra se riesce sì ma come
cazzo ragazza la sera non riesco a
prenderla male che schifo no si è caduto
aiuterà nota tutta chi ascoltava e
niente siamo a due
porca vacca partiamo con le questo ci
siete
facciamo le corse non era questa cosa
faccio io a swank blonde rating lo
riprendi presto
quindi niente toni f perfetto ok
perfetto va hai fatto a me mentre life
ha testé cagate io vado lì che ho
lasciate valore della guest era dobbiamo
andare a roma è una bistecca mi sono
piccola per caso ma è questa si adobe
stress ci siamo critici come morte dove
c'è un vicino non ci fosse questa destra
la destra quella tra la destra e notte
perché la libera via destra ciao amici
l'altra ma due teste di cazzo mi sono
lanciato da te l'ha catapultata vi prego
ok io comunque sempre la mia fa la mamma
mia che parchi allora può cerca di
capire dove quel punto secondo me e dove
sono io in questo momento per farvi
capire da va a scavare per terra
rischiava tutto però voglio che gli
premuto q michael mese di prova scala
scheletro maledetto di souk agathos 8
perché forse voleva di condividere con
noi il tesoro anche la presa sulla nave
carcere in coperta mai mai mai che
partiamo c'è una bella cosa dice la cina
dove la destra ecco bene abbiamo un
tesoro da ne abbiamo due tesori ha
acquistato uno come perdere i tesori
raga io ho paura che domani tra l'altro
con la barca si stia per muovere quindi
o muoviamo il culo in di medicazioni ma
quanto
no non riesco se la fa ce la fa ce la
fai brucia aia si sta sparando ho
chiesto speronata che cazzo porca vacca
poi moratti sparate ok la donna a
chiamare fare gli spara di ok ok ammazza
ammazza fripp tokyo giappone e l'ho
colpito due volte mano è morto
vai vai sulla nave come accessori e
ripartiamo poi se sarà ok non c'è niente
ragazzi ma non so se ha fondato la barca
sta affondando sto fondando non lo
lasciava il bayern della pace 1 c'è un
tizio qua sotto
questo ha ucciso questa è morta
riprendiamoci le nostre prime voci
ragazzi la nostra ci divertiamo tutto
quello che non ho sistema che ha sempre
animato affondando io anche noi anche la
nostra barca la qualità per favore
porca vacca ai ragazzi ho sempre detto
no no non c'è ma non la strada ma ancora
c'è ancora ragazzi l'ancora e mi sa di
sì dobbiamo toglierlo ci stiamo vivendo
è a sinistra però aspetta che non solo
ha parlato dove sono nate qui sotto e
piene piene di gente qua ci si becca
nome ucciso lui no dai loro non è vero
che sapremo tutta l'acqua ok perfetto
guardare messo invece ci sono state
riscontrate adesso io sta isola sulla
mappa non la vedo solo io stronzo guarda
non c'era una volta qua non c'è questo
c'è quest'isola sulla mappa
non c'è troviamo ragazzi se non c'è
sulla piastrina di auto del pesce
quest'isola sulla mappa mosaico
confermando per non lo vedo
ma non è questa può magari proprio è
stranissimo quindi c'è un'isola non
segna rosso la mappa c'è un'isola non
segnate sfigato assegna la patologia e
vai vai andiamo a letto
andiamo a vedere cosa c'è questa
iscritti di baradar ha battuto isola non
segnala che abbiamo due tesori io vi
consiglio per lei un iscritto gigante
more distrutto vaiano vederemo andiamo
andiamo andiamo a quest'ora il galeone
quello di pirati dei caraibi
l'olandese volante chiara vigo e c'era
poi tra l'altro gigantesco io anno in
fondo a vedere col mezzo invece
poi ci sono i poster vedo una luce
ragazzi qua e gesù ma non ci fosse un
relitto
niente ragazzo scendendo negli abissi
tali cioè non so dove son finito
comunque non credo ci sia nulla raga
perché spera che ha forse trovato
aspetta
no ragazzi fi ragazzi non fermi ho
trovato qualcosa ve lo giuro 38 st se in
credito ve lo giuro ho trovato una così
cribbio trattano accadermi una caverna
nascosta dove troverà aspetta che devo
ridevo riemergere forse moio ce l'ho
fatta ha fatto che se armato e entrato
in una caverna nascosta se tu entri non
so assolutamente come spiegarvelo se
entrate nella parte bassa del relitto in
fondo se lo percorrete entrate in una
specie di d d d d canyon subacqueo però
vi giuro che è stranissimo state basse
sotto il ricco
allora vi vengo a prendere bisogno ho
trovato la roba incredibile che noi non
vediamo neanche più il tuo nome non
sapere se l'aspetta aspetto aspetto è
riuscito a trovarlo per miracolo adesso
vengono guardati superficie d'amore
porca vacca non lo vedo non vedo la
scuola e jobs ora emerge ok dove sei
sasha e io percorso un coso che o mio
dio
vieni pietro seguimento sta morendo sto
morendo no non c'è più aria sasha mi sa
che è sceso dove ero sceso io non andare
avanti e che non ho ancora visto niente
devi correre di ricorrere pietro bisogna
dunque verrebbe a trenitalia
ho ricordi da vinitaly inter ma poi
all'uscita una volta velocissimo perché
se no mori ok sono diverso sono diverso
grazie se molto frutto
marco io e morto mentre mano ed ai
rigori dalla interna
non so cosa ci sia quattro giorni e si
vede
bella come cosa eh no non ho mai visto
non abbiamo visto che siamo solo ragazzi
che mi odiate perché chiudo gli episodi
a metà però è un vizio che ciò mi
dispiace e quindi ragazzi continuerò nel
prossimo episodio per adesso concludiamo
quanto mi piace anche paris hilton e
descrizione si schieri e noi ci vediamo
al prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]